and I believe that when I invest in
myself I invest in my future consistency
consistency consistency is the
difference maker and so how do you stay
consistent I'm gonna give you three tips
on how to do it
I'm telling you becoming a learning
machine and a person who invests in the
cell works
[Music]
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation eight seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message invest in
yourself over to you Joe Dispenza what
I'm going through change in my life or
Iowa have a specific outcome that I want
to create I love to get up early in the
morning that's my time I'm a 4:30 in the
morning guy because that's my time the
rest of the day I'm serving but I love
getting up early and changing and
working and having some time to myself
and I believe that when I invest in
myself I invest in my future and that
time in my in my morning nobody bothers
me because that's my time and because of
brain waves and brain chemistry the door
between the conscious mind and the
subconscious mind is more open and so if
I get up early and I'm kind of between
theta and alpha I don't have to work as
hard I'm not thinking I just kind of
relax into the moment in the evening I
always ask myself how did I do
how was one lifetime in one day where
did I fall from grace what happened and
so then when I look at seeing how I
reacted to someone or something or I
made the choice that I could have made a
better choice I naturally and we all do
this begin to think well if the same
situation happened again how would I do
it differently and that's they active
beginning to come up with a new plan the
act of rehearsing it in your mind begins
to install the circuits in your brain
priming your brain so that when the next
experience happens you could modify your
behavior to do it
job in life that's called plasticity so
it doesn't matter for me what meditation
I do any longer I like to just get up in
a new state of being people say to me
hey um I miss my meditation today like
I'm supposed to go like this or
something and I say to them eyes open or
eyes closed you know my eyes open or
eyes closed you know when you're
passionate about something you know when
people can't get up in the morning and
they can't get out of bed I'm gonna tell
you why because they can predict the
feeling of everything that's gonna
happen in their life and their bodies
resigned to the familiar it says how
another mundane day but remember when
you were a kid and you were going on a
field trip what happened then you were
up and dressed and ready to go before
your parents are up you know why cuz you
knew something unexpected was gonna
happen that's how we should live our
lives waking up with the understanding
to expect the unexpected and something
unusual should happen in our life as a
result of our efforts and it's just
those beginning moments where it begins
to happen that we begin to prove to
ourselves how powerful it really are so
take time in the morning in the evening
and the rest of the day check in with
yourself at certain times to see if
you're still in that energy and if
you're not excuse yourself for a second
raise your energy and step back into
your life if you keep doing that over
and over again you'll become less
frustrated less impatient less
judgmental it'll just become something
of the past and you'll be someone else
creating daily success routines is the
secret to getting everything that you
want everything that you want out of
life out of business your hopes your
dreams your ambitions everything that
you want lie on the other side of what
you are doing daily of your daily
success habits and routines I think we
let ourselves down by default I think we
worry about other people's opinions by
default I think we play small every day
by default I think you should have
already accomplished a lot of the things
that are on your list but you're stuck
in procrastination mode because you are
playing small by default because you are
not consistent because you do not have
the habits on a daily basis to keep
going consistency consistency
consistency
is the difference maker and so how do
you stay consistent I'm gonna give you
three tips on how to do it
number one is chart your start what you
do in the first 15 minutes of your day
matters chart your start have a plan of
action most people wake up like an
accident most people wake up they're
tired you pull out your phone you start
looking on your email and what are you
doing when you're looking at your email
or look in the social media you're
responding to other people's emergencies
you wake up you're tired and the first
thing you do is you start responding to
other people's emergencies I want you to
control the first part of your day chart
your start understand what it is that
makes you come alive understand what is
the action it helps you feel bold
creative unstoppable we've all had it
you've all had moments where you have
felt bold courageous and unstoppable
what led to that reverse-engineer
yourself what led to you feeling bold is
it watching the video is it reading a
book is it having a conversation is it
doing a meditation is it taking your dog
out for a walk is it cutting the grass
like I don't care there's no judgement I
don't care what the thing is that makes
you feel bold and courageous and
unstoppable I just want you to do it
daily I want you to start your day with
intention most people don't start their
day with intention and that makes a
difference between the people who
achieve success and the ones who don't
and so chart your start figure out the
thing that makes you come alive that
makes you feel like that big crazy idea
of yours is actually possible and put
that into the first 15 minutes of every
day if you did the thing that made you
feel bold courageous and unstoppable in
the first 15 minutes of waking up every
single day not every day will be amazing
but I guarantee you that your life will
look unrecognizable from where you are
right now chart your start number two is
flex TX one of the things I love doing
is I get an annual calendar I'm working
on making a custom-branded one here but
an annual calendar and every time that
you hit your main goals you cross it off
and what you want to do is not break the
pattern right flex the X we're getting
strong rah and you're building momentum
I'm a big fan of momentum I think we
don't have enough momentum in our lives
in our businesses and towards our goals
where will you see something like this
where you see that I
before I've been doing it for months you
don't want to break the pattern and so
flexing the ex feel proud about every
single time that you do the thing that
you want to do so for me the two most
important habits that I have on here one
is fasting until noon and so the only
thing I haven't before noon is a coffee
or tea or some water and then 30 minutes
of cardio so I'm running for 30 minutes
a day I went to Boston and we got in at
3:00 in the morning we drove all the way
there and I was really tired but I
wanted to get my ex and so three o'clock
everybody's going to sleep I'm still
running for half an hour the only
exceptions if I'm super sick if I'm on
medication which doesn't really happen
that often then I'll give myself a break
then I'll be gentle on myself but most
of the time it's not that you can't do
it most of the time it's something
you're not able to do it you're just
procrastinating you're just being lazy
you just being tired and so having a
system like this where you can flex the
X is super important so that you build
momentum you build you build you build
momentum to actually accomplishing the
habits because success is a habit
because again everything you wanted a
life is on the other side of you doing
the consistent habits every single day
and when you can track them like this
and feel the momentum it's so much
easier to keep going
flex the X and number three is your
actions have to map to your ambitions
what I love doing and as an entrepreneur
we love being planners we love thinking
about the life that we want to have in a
schedule that we want to create is
what's in your calendar allowing you to
accomplish your goals do your actions
map to your ambitions it's great to be
motivated it's great to watch a video
like this it's great to get some ideas
your best immediate course of action is
now looking at your calendar in st. if I
did these actions from from Sunday to
Sunday and put your life in there from
the relationships that you want to have
from the business growth you want to
have every goal that you have business
and personal if you did the actions that
were in your calendar would you come
closer to accomplishing those goals and
for too many of you it's know for to
many of you you have ideas you have
ambitions you have Drive you have goals
and hopes and dreams but then when you
look at what's actually in your calendar
you're spending very little time when
moving the ball forward on those goals
now I get it maybe you have a full-time
job maybe you have other
responsibilities great that's okay the
goal is to make those chunks bigger
towards spending on our dreams and goals
but even those little actions like your
first actually maybe I need to quit my
job I need to make enough money so that
I can quit my job and do me this
entrepreneurship thing full-time awesome
let me look at your calendar are you
spending enough time every week doing
the activities that you need to do so
you can build your business to the point
where you can quit your job do your
actions map to your ambitions and so
it's great to come up with a list of
goals and dreams and we're gonna hit
these targets in 30 days and it's it's
super fun to do those exercises what's
more important than just having those
goals is the habits it's what's in your
schedule making sure your actions map to
your ambitions and so great have your
goals but then immediately like right
now dive into your calendar every day of
the week and look if I did these things
if I did everything according to my
schedule
assuming you're gonna stick to your
schedule right if you did all those
things would you be moving closer to
accomplishing the life that you want yes
or no and if it's no that needs to make
corrections and that's where too many of
you are falling down and I want to see
you when your actions need to map to
your ambitions now I've got a really
special bonus clip that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for question of the day I want to know
how are you gonna chart your start I
want to know what is the single biggest
change you're gonna make to your morning
routine the thing that will make you
feel bold and courageous every day what
are you gonna do starting tomorrow
morning let me know leave it down in the
comments below
people hits your mental skills how do
you control your thoughts emotion
because you know I have a bad temper and
I'll lose my temper nobody likes me so
emotion and then it's physical skills if
I look like you know a bag of dirt and
I'm not strong people pick up on that
health is important though that and
that's spiritual you know I don't cheat
on my wife I don't cheat on my customers
I don't cheat people I don't cut corners
if I can't do something I'll tell you up
front if I screw up I'll tell you you
know I mean I mean as you and I know
there's a lot of scum out there or
entrepreneurs but they have bad personal
skills they have bad responsibilities
skills they're not legal ethical moral
spiritual and I think today the way the
world's got you better legal ethical
moral approach I'm telling you becoming
a learning machine and a person who
invests in the cell works I invest at
least a hundred thousand dollars a month
in my own education literally 100 G's a
month not a year I got a CPA back that
number up I've shown it it's it's
obvious to if you watch my snapchat
traveling mentors coaches consultants
that I pay and I've been doing that for
years and it's funny the more I invested
myself every year my income has gone up
massively some people go oh well I'm not
gonna pay for stuff I'm just gonna
google it well go ahead but I'm telling
you there is a magic it investing in
yourself people get it invested in real
estate is good oh okay I do that invest
in stock market that's good I buy land i
oh I'm investing by businesses it's all
good but nothing touches the ROI on
investing in my own brain I'm gonna save
money this is what you hear if you look
on the internet how do I make money
first thing you got to do is you got to
save money
what do you hear the politicians say the
middle class I'm here to save it what if
there is no middle class and it was just
made up to keep the people civil
see see see see that that's how you're
gonna play this game you got to be
available people have to know you don't
talk to strangers strangers got
everything you want me everything you
want a stranger's got it [ __ ] your
friends ain't got nothing right it fits
up to your friend [ __ ] that you're done
you're like all my friends are broke I'm
25 years old everybody around me was
broke okay
my mama was scared every time my mama
Tuesday Tuesday she's clipping coupons
that was some reason to get the
newspaper [ __ ] the coupons are coming
she would sit there and clip a man she
had him in the little box I learned that
for you for 16 years I watched my mom do
that for 16 years my mom would tell me
hey grant turn those lights up turn
those lights up me and my twin brother
turn those lights on from across the
house she could hear me walk out of my
bedroom 75 feet away is a turn those
damn lights off I told you okay twin
brothers okay I'm I'm sixteen years old
my twin brother my mom said when you
guys go pee do it together
saves water saves water right okay
when my mom fed me cuz mama I had a
great mom how many of you had great
parents give you give your parents great
aunt huh hey just because they were
great payers doesn't mean they weren't
confused right because my mama was
confused man my mom did not know how to
make money she had no education she had
no ability she had never held a job she
did not know how to get money so what
she had to do was protect a little bit
of money she had seller be sold she was
sold on conservation reduce risk
don't spend contract protected defend it
you understand diversified have a lot of
little bets all over the place okay lots
a little bit she should never have a lot
of bets all over the place until you're
extremely wealthy when you're trying to
get wealthy you want to literally you
want to go all-in and it not be a bet
you need to know the space so well that
you're like I know for sure this was
gonna work what do you know we'll pay
you every time for sure if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you up or that would
be like a little beacon if you liked
this video and you want more Joe
Dispenza check out the top 10 rules
video I did on him the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there we always have to update our
versions about reality because it's the
only way that we adapt